ATTENDANCE. ALAN ARCHULETA AT
KANSAS STATE BACKER BOARD JESS
BRADFORD CUT BY ADAM CORTESE
DALLEY DODD DURAZO AIKMAN
GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE HURTS
BURKE WAY SO HER TADO JONES CAN
LONGER LAYERED LLEVA LA MON
LOCAL FIRE MELINDA'S MAN NEWMAN.
NIELSEN A SHOW OF BOTH OKAY.
FORTUNE TINO ROTH ZERO SKINNER
STERN NUMBER WAIT CASKEY WEINER
WELL. A QUORUM IS PRESENT GOOD
MORNING LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF
THE SENATE WE'RE GOING TO GET
STARTED WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
SENATOR GONZALES AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG BY SENATOR NEWMAN.
CONSIDER GONZALEZ LOVING GOD
SOMETIMES WHEN WE PRAY YOU GIVE
US GIFTS THAT WE DIDN'T ASK FOR
I ASKED FOR STRENGTH AND I WAS
GIVEN DIFFICULTIES TO MAKE ME
STRONG I ASKED FOR WISDOM AND I
WAS GIVEN PROBLEMS TO SOLVE. I
ASKED FOR PROSPERITY AND I WAS
GIVEN BRAIN AND BRAWN TO WORK.
I ASK FOR COURAGE AND I WAS
GIVEN DANGER TO OVERCOME. I
ASKED FOR PATIENCE AND I WAS
PLACED IN SITUATIONS WHERE I
HAD TO WAIT. I ASKED FOR LOVE
AND I WAS GIVEN TROUBLED PEOPLE
TO HELP. I ASKED FOR FAVORS AND
I WAS GIVEN OPPORTUNITIES. I
RECEIVED NOTHING I ASKED FOR
AND I RECEIVED EVERYTHING I
NEEDED. WE GIVE YOU THANKS GOD
FOR YOU KNOW WHAT WE NEED
COMMENT. THE COLLEGE PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. HE HAS. ISRAEL ALL.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION OUR
FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS WILL BE
CONSIDERATION OF THE BUDGET
BILL A PACKAGE BUT BEFORE WE
PROCEED WE WILL MOVE TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS FOR PROCEDURAL
PURPOSES SENATOR SCANNER FOR
WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RIGHT FIVE
A PROCEDURAL MOTION MEMBERS I
MOVED TO RE SUSPEND THE SENATE
RULES AS THEY RELATE TO
ASSEMBLY BILLS ONE THIRTY AND
ONE SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER SENATOR NIELSEN.
I OBJECT AND ASK FOR A ROLL
CALL VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR
NELSON- THE CENTER SKINNER HAS
A MOTION HE'S ASKING FOR A VOTE
CENTER NELSON IS ASKING FOR A
NO VOTE. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA I.
ATKINS I FACE NO BACKER HI
BORJAS NO BRADFORD. I COME BY
ADAM HI CORTESE HI DALLY NO
DODD HI TORONTO HI HI ADNAN.
GLAZER HI FIVE DOLLARS HIGH
GROWTH. HERTZBERG FIVE WEST SO
HI HER TADO I JONES NO KAMMERER
FIVE LAYERED HI LLEVA HI THE
MON. MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO
MEN HI NEWMAN HI NIELSEN NO A
SHOW OF BOTH. NO TAN HI FORTUNE
TINO HI ROSS HI RUBIO. HI
SKINNER HI STERN HI I'M BURKE
HI WHAT KIND OF SKI HI WINNER.
WELL NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN EGGMAN. I GROVE.
LIMONIUM WEINER. SIZE TWENTY
EIGHT KNOWS EIGHT MOTION PASSES
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO ON THE
BUDGET. EIGHTY ONE SIXTY ONE
SENATOR SKINNER. THE PROTESTS
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING AN ACT
RELATING TO THE STATE BUDGET
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BELL.
THERE'S GOING TO BE ON THE
COURT. THANK YOU SO MUCH MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB ONE SIXTY
ONE IS THE SECOND BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR ASSOCIATED WITH OUR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET AT.
MOST SIGNIFICANTLY THIS BILL
AUGMENTS THE FINES. THAT
DEDICATED FOR COUNTIES TO
OPERATE THE RECALL ELECTION BY
TWENTY EIGHT POINT FOUR
MILLION. TO A TOTAL OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE POINT
SIX MILLION. THIS IS BASED ON
UPDATED ESTIMATES THAT THE
COUNTY'S PROVIDED. THE WEAPON
THE SECRETARY OF STATE. THIS
BILL ALSO SPECIFIES THAT IN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
GENERAL FUNDS MAY BE MADE
AVAILABLE FOR WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND FOREST
RESILIENCE ACTIVITIES IN THIS
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
FISCAL YEAR. IT ALSO MAKES
OTHER TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING
CHANGES AND I ASK THE ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER- ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON AB ONE
SIXTY ONE SENATOR NIELSEN.
PRESIDENT LAID DOWN THE SENATE
I AM DISPOSED TO SUPPORTERS
MONEY FOR THE WILD LAND
PROTECTION BUT I KIND OF OBJECT
TO THE AMOUNT OF AUTHORITY THAT
WE'RE GIVING THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN THIS THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT THEY'VE
ALREADY FAILED US. IN THIS AND
I'M JUST DISTRUSTFUL OF WHAT
THEY MAY DO WHEN WE PUT FORWARD
MONEY TO CLEAN UP THE FOURTH
AND WHILE LANCE AND THEN THEY
DON'T. ALLOW IT TO HAPPEN. AND
THAT THAT THAT SPEECH TO THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH AUTHORITY THAT
WE ARE NOT. GIVE THEM. THANK
YOU SENATOR MAYOR DALLY. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS I ALSO
WANTED TO DESCRIBE YESTERDAY WE
HAD A REALLY VIGOROUS DEBATE ON.
THE OTHER HALF THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND WHERE THE
MONEY ACTUALLY GO SO THERE'S
GOING TO BE. A TRAILER BILL
THAT WILL BE FOLLOWING I
BELIEVE IT'S A RESOURCES
TRAINER BILL. DON'T KNOW THE
NUMBER BUT- WE ALLOCATED IN
SEPT TWO MOST OF THE MONEY TO
GO TO CAL FIRE AND CAL FIRE IS
BEEN. BUSY AS YOU KNOW RIGHT
NOW FIGHTING FIRES AND WE NEED
TO THE OTHER AGENCIES THAT WE
ALLOCATED MONEY TO LIKE THE
CONSERVANCY'S THE FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS AND THOSE FOLKS.
ACTUALLY DISPERSE THEIR MONEY
AND THERE'S STILL A NEED FOR
MORE MONEY SO. I WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT ONE WEEK YOU
HAVE THE TRAILER BILL THAT WE
PUT THAT MONEY INTO DIFFERENT
THOSE OTHER PARTS OF THE OF THE
PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY CAN GET
THE MONEY ON THE GROUND AND I.
JUST TOOK SOME- INFORMATION
JUST FROM MY LOCAL OUR CD AND
FIRE SAFE COUNCIL OF FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS WITH THE
PROJECTS THAT ARE. READY TO GO
HAVE THE SECRET DONE. AND JUST
NEED THE FUNDS SO I WOULD
ENCOURAGE AND I'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH OTHER MEMBERS- THAT WE
WOULD. IN THE TRAINER BILL MAKE
SURE WE TAKE THAT MONEY AND NOT
GIVE TO CAL FIRE WHO. CAN'T GET
IT OUT. BUT GIVEN TO AGENCIES
THAT CAN ACTUALLY DISPERSE THE
FUNDS AND GET ON THE GROUND AND
ACTUALLY INCREASED AMOUNT OF
ACRES THAT WE NEED TO BE
TREATING IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR
DELHI SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT AND- SHE THE WORK
DONE HERE I WOULD JUST HAVE. A
FEW SLIGHTLY- THE POSTURE THIS
ITEM I WOULD SAY THAT- THE
ADMINISTRATION ACTUALLY UP TO
THIS POINT HAS DONE AN
INCREDIBLY EFFECTIVE JOB OF
MITIGATING WILDFIRE RISK THIS
IS A PROBLEM THAT KEEPS GROWING
THOUGH AND IT'S BIGGER THAN ANY
OF US I THINK FULLY IMAGINE
ESPECIALLY WITH THE EVOLVING
DROUGHT CONDITIONS BUT- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER I THOUGHT
NEEDED EXCELLENT POINT ABOUT
UTILIZING REGIONALISM. LOCALISM
AS WE PUSH FORWARD I HEARD VERY
GOOD SIGNALS FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN THAT RESPECT- SO
APPRECIATE THE URGENCY OF THIS
MATTER AND I THINK THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR A BIG
BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT ON ON
SOMETHING ROBUST GOING FORWARD
SO. WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
ARRIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
STERN ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON. FOLLOW HIM TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY ONE SIXTY ONE ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CENTER SKINNER WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU SO MUCH- JUST
IN REFERENCE TO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS- YES THERE IS A FIRE
PREVENTION GRANT PROGRAM IN OUR
EARLY ACTION. THERE WAS A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
MILLION. THAT WAS FOR GRANTS
AND THOSE GRANTS WERE FOR SUCH
THINGS AS FIRE SAFE COUNCILS
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
LOCAL AGENCIES AND OTHERS. AND
THAT EARLY ACTION PLAN. WHICH
IS LIKELY TO BE THE
ARCHITECTURE. THAT IS THE BASIS
FOR OUR DISCUSSION THIS SUMMER
ON THE WILDFIRE PACKAGE WHICH
WE WILL TAKE ACTION ON. IN-
PROBABLY WHEN WE RETURNED FROM
BREAK- AND IN THAT WILDFIRE
PACKAGE. WE WILL DESIGNATE
MONEY INCLUDING THIS FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION SO WE WILL BE
TAKING A- ONCE WE HAVE
DISCUSSIONS ON HOW THAT FUNDING
SHOULD BE DIVIDED WE WILL BE
TAKING. FUTURE ACTION AND WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER'S
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA HI ATKINS HI
BABY HI BECKER HI FORGES BY
BRADFORD. HI BY ADAM I CORTESE
FIVE DALLY I DONT. HI ZERO.
FIVE ADMIN HI GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH HIGH
HURTS BURKE HI WITH SO. HI TIDO
HI JONES I CAN'T LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA HI THE MOUNT.
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S I MEN FIVE
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. HI A TRAIL
OF BOTH HI PAM HI FORTUNE TINO.
HI ROTH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER HI
STERN HI I'M BURKE I LIKE HOW
TO SKI HI WEINER. WELL HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN FIVE. THE MON. WINNER.
HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
MAJOR PASSES A MEMBERS WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO FILE I'M
TWENTY ONE WHICH IS. ALSO
SENATOR SKINNER. ON A. B. ONE
THIRTY. AND US SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY
BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AN ACT RELATING TO
EDUCATION FINANCE AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. YES. DON'T GO.
YEAH. IT'S LIKE IT'S LIKE.
SEVENTY SEARS CANADA YOU HAVE
THE FLOOR. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AT ONE THIRTY
IT IS OUR TRAILER BILL ON A K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION. ENDED
CONTAIN STATUTORY CHANGES TO
EMPLOYMENT THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT. AND THE
STATUTORY CHANGES INCLUDE IT
ENABLES US TO PROCEED WITH THE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAM BEGINNING IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE SCHOOL
YEAR ENDED TV'S UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX.
NOW I WILL NOTE THAT THIS BILL
DOES NOT INCLUDE THE CHILDCARE.
PACIFIC'S WE DID HOWEVER ACT IN
OUR BUDGET BILL WE ACTED TO
FIND CHILDCARE. BUT SINCE
CHILDCARE WAS REMOVED FROM THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT FINDING WE
ARE NOT DOING IT IN THIS BILL
AND WE WILL DO IT SUBSEQUENTLY.
BUT TOGETHER. THE TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM THE
CHILDCARE ACTIONS THAT WE WILL
WE HAVE TAKEN AND WE WILL TAKE
AS WELL AS THE EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM
IN THIS BILL. THAT WILL PROVIDE
TICKET STUDENTS T. K. THROUGH
GRADE SIX WITHACCESS TO AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS. AND PROGRAMS
DURING BREAKS SUCH AS SUMMER
RECESS. SO THAT WE CAN REALLY
ACHIEVE GOOD CARE AND EDUCATION
FOR OUR CHILDREN FOR A FULL DAY
TWENTY FIVE THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
THE ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
AMENDS THE INDEPENDENT STUDY
PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES HAVE AN OPTION TO
CONTINUE DISTANCE LEARNING. IN
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
SCHOOL YEAR IT INCREASES THE
VALUE OF THE CONCENTRATION
GRANT OUT ON ADJUSTMENT AS PART
OF OUR LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA CALCULATION SO IT IT
JUST SAID FROM 50% 265% ON THE
BASE GRANT. AND SPECIFIES THAT
THIS INCREASED FUNDING BE USED
TO INCREASE SCHOOL SITE
STAFFING INCLUDING CUSTODIAL
STAFF. IT INCREASES ONGOING
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDING FOR
THE CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAM. BY A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION ON
GOING. REQUIRES LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES IN THIS
ONE I THINK THAT WE SHOULD ALL
BE PARTICULARLY PROUD OF
BECAUSE IT MAKES US THE FIRST
STATE TO DO SO IT ENSURES THAT
OUR K. THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS
IF THEY WANT TO HAVE A MEAL AT
SCHOOL THEY'RE ENTITLED TO TWO
MEALS. IN THE SCHOOL DAY
WITHOUT BURDENSOME PAPERWORK
AND WITHOUT OTHER GROUPS THAT
THEY HAVE TO FOLLOW IN HIS WE
KNOW A HUNGRY CHILD DOES NOT
LEARN WELL THERE'S ANY NUMBER
OF REASONS A CHILD MAKES SHOW
UP AT SCHOOL HUNGRY THIS WILL
ALLEVIATE THAT AND IT IS A
GREAT ACTION. ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL HAS SOME VERY RESPONSIBLE
BUDGETING AS OUR SUB ONE CHAIR
SENATOR FROM SANTA CRUZ POINTED
OUT IN OUR HEARING YESTERDAY IT
FULLY PAYS OFF. THE DEFERRALS
FOR IN OUR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO OUR PROPERTY NINETY EIGHT
PAYMENT DEFERRALS AND ALSO
CONTRIBUTES TO OUR PROP NINETY
EIGHT RAINY DAY FUND AND I
BELIEVE FOR THE FIRST TIME- AND
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER'S SENATOR NIELSEN. AND
I HAVE AN AMENDMENT AT THE DESK
THANK YOU CENTER NELSON HAS
MEMBERS AT THE DESK SECRETARY
PLEASE READ AMENDMENTS BY
SENATOR NIELSEN SET ONE.
SENATOR NELSON LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE THIS
AMENDMENT WOULD. REMOVE UNITIVE.
AT A CHARTER MORATORIUM. YOU
KNOW CHANGE IT. THE ATTACK BY
SOME ENTITIES THE PROCESS ON
CHARTER SCHOOLS WILL NEVER
NEVER END. THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
ARE A MAGNIFICENT OPPORTUNITY
AN OPTION FOR OUR PARENTS ON
THE GROWTH OF CHARTER SCHOOLS.
HAS BEEN MOSTLY BECAUSE OF THE
SUPPORT FROM THE ETHNIC
COMMUNITIES. HELLO THING THAT
THEIR CHILDREN HAD BEEN HARMED.
BUT PUBLIC EDUCATION. AND WHO
ARE SEEKING THE OPPORTUNITY OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS FOR THEIR
STUDENTS. HI THIS IS A NEW
OBJECT AND THAT'S WHAT THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE GOING TO DO IN
THE BUDGET TO TAKE THESE- THESE
PUNITIVE MEASURES AND THE
MORATORIUM. ON THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS AFTER. THANK YOU
SINNERS NEVER DENIED NELSON'S
PRESENTING AMENDMENTS- FOR THIS
BILL SENATOR HERTZBERG PURPOSE
YOU'RE RIGHT THANK YOU VERY-MUCH MR PRESIDENT IS INJURED OR
MAKES A MOTION TO LAY THE
MEMBERS ON THE TABLE WITH WHICH
WE DON'T EVEN HAVE A BEFORE
SCHOOL THEM ON THE TABLE. THANK
YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG IS ASKING
FOR THE MEMBERS TO BE LAID ON
THE TABLE ON THIS MOTION CENTER
HERTZBERG IS ASKING FOR AN I.
VOTE SENATOR NELSON IS ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS. HI FACE NO
BACKER HI FORGES NO BRADFORD I
HAVE A HI CORTESE. HI DALLY NO
DODD. HI THERE ARE SO BY ADMIN
HI LASER HI CONSOLIDATE HIGH
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG HI WHERE
SO. HI HER TADO. HI JONES NO
CAN WALKER I LAYERED HI LLEVA
HI LYNN MON HI MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MEN HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. NO TELEVOTE NO TAN HI
FORTUNE TINO HI ROSS HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER HI STERN. HI AMBERG
HI WHITE HOUSE SKI HI WINNER.
WELL NOW. HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS
NINE THE MOTION TO LAY ON THE
TABLE IS A DOT IS PASSED OUT
WE'RE GOING BACK TO THE BILL.
SENATORS FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE.
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY CENTER LABOR
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
SAY THAT THIS IS REALLY A NEW
AND EXCITING TIME FOR EDUCATION
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA NOT
ONLY ARE WE FULLY FUNDING A
THROUGH G. SO ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS IN THE STATE WILL HAVE
ACCESS THROUGH EIGHT TWO EIGHT
THREE G. COURSES ME THEY WILL
THEN BE ABLE TO GO TO A
UNIVERSITY OR A C. ISSUE IF
THEY SO CHOOSE. WE'RE ALSO
DOUBLING THE AMOUNT OF C. T. E.
MONEY THAT WE ARE GOING WE ARE
GOING TO THERE IS IN THIS
BUDGET AND I'VE SAID FOR YEARS
THAT WE HAVE TO PROVIDE BOTH
FOR OUR STUDENTS WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR STUDENTS
HAVE OPTIONS IN C. T. E. BUT
ALSO THE OPTION TO GO TO
COLLEGE SO I THINK IN THIS
BUDGET WE HAVE FINALLY GOTTEN
THERE AND IT'S VERY EXCITING.
WE'RE ALSO RAISING THE PER
PUPIL SPENDING FROM
1-300-022-0000 IT IS MY HOPE
THAT OUR ELEAZAR OUR SCHOOLS OR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WILL USE THIS
MONEY TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
A MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL AT
EVERY SCHOOL OR TWO DEPENDING
ON THE SIZE OF YOUR SCHOOL OR
THREE. THAT THERE'S A SCHOOL
NURSE AT EVERY SCHOOL THAT
EVERY STUDENT HAS WHAT THEY
NEED TO SUCCEED BEING IT IN
TEXTBOOKS. AND IN. PHONE
TABLETS SO I DOES RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND FEEL THIS IS
REALLY AN EXCITING DAY FOR
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU SENATOR LABOR SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE I ALSO STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB ONE THIRTY- AS A
CURRENT TEACHER ON LEAVE AND
FORMER SEVENTEEN YEAR TEACHER I
ALSO WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT SOME
OF THE ITEMS THAT ARE CRITICAL
TO THE SUCCESS OF OUR CHILDREN
WELL FIRST OF ALL I AM SO
PLEASED TO SEE THAT OUR
STUDENTS WILL BE FAD IT IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT OUR
STUDENTS COME PREPARED. AND
IT'S NOT ONLY FOR THEIR
LEARNING BUT ALSO FOR THEIR
NUTRITION AND I MANY TIMES HAD
FOOD IN MY CLASSROOM JUST
BECAUSE OUR KIDS CAME INTO THE
CLASSROOM SO HUNGRY AND I KNEW
THAT I HAD TO FEED THEM AND SO
I'M SO PROUD THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE THAT WE'VE INCLUDED
THAT IN THE BUDGET. AND I ALSO
WANT TO SAY THAT YOU KNOW I SEE
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION IS
KEY TO THE SUCCESS OF THE
STUDENTS I'VE SEEN SO MANY KIDS
COME AND- YOU KNOW I'M NOT
BEING ABLE TO HOLD A PENCIL.
WHILE THEIR COUNTERPARTS
ALREADY READING TWO THREE
READING LEVELS ABOVE THEM AND
SO THIS WILL HELP LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD AND I THINK. THIS
CREEK IMPORTANT ALSO FOR
TEACHERS- DURING THE PANDEMIC I
HAD SO MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
CALLING INTO SHARING HOW
EXHAUSTED THEY WERE. HOW TIRED
THEY WORK EVEN THOUGH THEY
ALWAYS DID IT WITH A SMILE AND
ALWAYS WERE PREPARED THEY
REALLY WERE PLEADING FOR
SUPPORT IN THIS. AREA AND SOME
REALLY ALSO VERY PROUD THEY
WERE ABLE TO. TO INVEST IN
EARLY CHILD. EDUCATION BECAUSE
IT PREPARES OUR STUDENTS
BETTER. AND THAT ALSO HELPS OUR
TEACHERS NOT TO STAR STUDENTS
AND- I'M WITH THAT I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO THIS
LEGISLATURE TO. THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO EVERYONE THAT
WORKED ON THIS AND TO ALL THE
TEACHERS OUT THERE. WE WANT TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT THAT WE HEAR
YOU WE UNDERSTAND YOU AND TO
ALL THE PARENTS OUT THERE THEY
COULDN'T. GET THEIR KIDS TO. AT
T. K. NOW YOU CAN AND SO WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO
SENATOR BECKER. THANK YOU BUT
YOU'RE SO SEE MY COMMENTS WITH
THE CENTER FROM CHINO. IS IT
THIS IS IN STARK BILL. AS IS MY
TIME TO CHARGE YOUR PARTITIONS
COUNCIL HAVE BEEN A STRONG
ADVOCATE OF EARLY LEARNING. AND
WE KNOW THAT INVESTMENTS IN
EARLY LEARNING PAY STRONG
DIVIDENDS. DOWN THE ROAD AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT
BEGINS THE INVESTMENT IN EARLY
LEARNING. REALLY HISTORIC
INTESTINE ACROSS THE BOARD LOOK
FORWARD TO ADDING A GREAT
REFORM. A TO THOSE EFFORTS BUT
THIS BILL WITH EARLY LEARNING
WITH THE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
PARTNERSHIPS HAS SO MANY.
HISTORIC IMPORTANT ELEMENTS AND
I STRONGLY- RISE AND-
REQUESTING A VOTE. THE SAME
BECKER CENTER LAYERED. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I THINK I
WANTED TO. SORT OF ENCAPSULATED
TORT TALLADEGA WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE ON K. THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION AND FIRST LET ME
REALLY THANK THE SENATORS FROM
YUCAIPA AND IRVINE WHO ROUNDED
OUT BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ONE
WHEN WE APPROVED THE BUDGET BUT
TOGETHER WITH THE ASSEMBLY WE
PROVED ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED
INDIVIDUAL MOTIONS IT WAS THE
RESULT OF THIRTEEN HEARING
SERVICE A RESULT OF HUNDREDS
AND HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
TESTIFYING. AND PART OF THE
BUDGET IS NOT IN THE TRAILER
BILL TODAY THE GLOBAL PART AND
IT IS REALLY WORTH CALLING OUT
BECAUSE IT'S THE BACKDROP FOR
WHAT WE'RE APPROVING TODAY WE
HAVE AN PROP NINETY EIGHT A
RESTORATION TO WHERE IT WAS
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND A FIVE
POINT 007% COST OF LIVING
INCREASE. WHICH PUTS OUR
SPENDING ON K. THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION AT A RECORD LEVEL WE
ALSO FOR THE FIRST TIME HAVE A
RAINY DAY FUND AS SPECIFIED BY
THE PROPOSITION THE VOTERS
ADOPTED IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN A RAINY DAY FUND JUST
FOR EDUCATION SO WE HAVE
ROUGHLY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
WHEN WE ADOPT THIS BUDGET. THAT
WILL BE A RAINY DAY FUND OF
FOUR WHEN EVER WE HIT THE NEXT
RECESSION ADDITIONALLY THERE IS
STILL IN THE BUDGET A BUY DOWN
AN ASSIST OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOR
PURSE AND STIRRERS THAT WILL BE
A BIG HELP AND WITH ALL THAT A
A BACKDROP. WELL THE THINGS
THAT THE SENATOR FROM CHINO AND
THE SENATOR FROM SAN MATTEO
COUNTY AND OTHERS THAT HAVE
SPOKEN REALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE
THE ONE OF THE KEY ONES IS THAT
THE BUDGET AS PROPOSED IN THE
MAY REVISE DID NOT PAY OFF THE
SCHOOL DEFERRALS FOR K. THROUGH
TWELVE THIS BUDGET DOGS SO THAT
ANY SCHOOL DISTRICT AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THAT WENT INTO DEBT.
IN FEAR OF PANDEMIC CUTS WE'LL
HAVE THAT. FOR A REAL A DISH.
AS WAS SAID BY THE BUDGET
CHAIR. BY THIS SETS FORWARD-
THE INDEPENDENT STUDIES AND WE
RUN THE RISK OF FUNDING
DECLINING ENROLLMENT BECAUSE OF
KIDS THAT DON'T COME BACK WHEN
SCHOOLS FULLY RE OPEN WHICH WE
WERE ALL LOOKING FORWARD TO IN
AUGUST AND SEPTEMBER. BUT IF
THERE IS A PARENT OR GUARDIAN
THAT IS WORRIED ABOUT A HEALTH
CHALLENGE. VAN THIS GIVES AN
ALTERNATIVE AND WE WILL IN TURN
NOT BE FUNDING DECLINING
ENROLLMENT A NEXT YEAR. THERE'S
MONEY HERE FOR SPECIAL ED.
BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT WE HEARD
SO THERE IS A ONE TIME MAJOR
SPENDING TOWARD SPECIAL
EDUCATION SIMILARLY CAREER
TECH. SO THIS IS PROBABLY THE
BEST BUDGET IN MODERN TIMES FOR
K. THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION.
THIS TRAILER BILL IMPLEMENTED
ALL THOSE CHANGES SO I WILL BE
PROUD TO SUPPORT IT AND ASK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR AN IPHONE. THANK
YOU SENATOR LAYERED SENATOR
GLAZER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I CERTAINLY JOIN WITH
MIKE- MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES IN
EXPRESSING APPRECIATION TO THE
BUDGET CHAIR AND DO OUR
BUDGETS- ONE CHAIR- THIS BILL
AT WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE
BUDGET PROBABLY MOST IMPORTANT
BUDGET ISSUE THAT IS COMING
BEFORE THIS FLORIDA HAS SO MANY
THINGS IN THERE THAT ARE
IMPORTANT AS MANY OF MY.
COMMENT IN A BILL THAT HAS SO
MUCH AND IT'S THAT THERE'S
ALWAYS SOMETHING AT LEAST THAT
IT MAY BE ONE DOESN'T LIKE I
WANT TO JUST NOTE THE RARE
EXCEPTION FOR ME. AND THAT'S
THE MORATORIUM ON NINE NINE
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS.
THAT DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
THOSE THOSE PROGRAMS IN
PARTICULAR. WERE LIFESAVERS FOR
SO MANY FAMILIES AND THEIR
KIDS. BECAUSE OF THE EXPERTISE.
BUT THOSE CHARTER SCHOOLS HAD
DEVELOPED. IN THOSE TYPES OF
REMOTE. LEARNING PROGRAMS NOW.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME RARE
PROBLEMS IN THIS SPACE. WE HAD
A BILL THAT PASSED FOR A MONTH
OR SO AGO THAT ADDRESS THAT
PARTICULAR PROBLEM.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT THE BILL HAS
BEEN DENIED A HEARING- IN THE
ASSEMBLY THE FIX THAT. UNIQUE
PROBLEMS AND A NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOL THE
MORATORIUM I THINK GOES TOO FAR
TO TIME WHEN WE SHOULD BE DOING
THE OPPOSITE BUT OTHER THAN
THAT THIS IS A WONDERFUL BILL
WITH MANY GREAT THINGS IN IT
AND I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY. THANK YOU SARAH GLAZER
ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING
NINE CENTER SCANNER YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE THE- GOOD-
ADD DESCRIPTIONS BY MY
COLLEAGUES OF THE OTHER MANY
GOOD THINGS IN THIS BILL
WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER'S
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
BASE. BACKER I PORCHES I
BRADFORD I HAVE A HI CORTESE HI
DALLY. DODD FIVE DURAZO HI
ADNAN HI GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ HI
GROSS. HERTZBERG HI WITH SO HI-
TANTO HI JONES. CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA. HI THE MON HI
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEED NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. PHOTO
OF BOTH HI TAM FIVE FORTUNE
TINO. HI ROSS HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER HI STERN I AM BERG HI
WHITE HOUSE SKI HI WINNER. WELL
HI. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BASE TALLY NO. GROVE
JONES. NIELSEN WEINER. HIGHS
THIRTY THREE NOS TWO MAJOR
PASSES THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER- SENATOR HERTZBERG
FLEET WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RIGHT
THANK YOU AND YOUR MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS SENATORS THERE'S A
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL OF THE
DESK. BY OUR COLLEAGUE SENATOR
WIENER AND THE JEWISH CAUCUS
RELATIVE TO THIS MEASURE AB ONE
THIRTY IT'S BEEN REVIEWED BY
BOTH CAUCUSES AND I ASK THAT
THIS LETTER BE APPROVED. THANK
YOUS CENTERS FOR WITHOUT
OBJECTION. IT'S APPROVED. ALL
RIGHT WE ARE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO THE REGULAR ORDER OF
BUSINESS MEMBERS MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED RED
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS ARE
THEIR MEMBERS. THAT ARE WISHING
TO BE RECOGNIZED UNDER MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS. SENATOR
HERTZBERG THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MEMBERS I MOVED THE ADOPTION-
OF AUTHORS AMENDMENTS FOR
MEASURES ACROSS THE DESK ON
FRIDAY SATURDAY AND SUNDAY JULY
NINE JULY TENTH AND JULY ELEVEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE ADOPTED
PUBLISHED IN THE MEASURES
RETURN TO COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
SIR HERS BERG- SENATOR NIELSEN.
FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE ON THE
WAITER SAYS THIS IS MORE DOING
BUSINESS OVER THE WEEKEND AND-
I THINK WE NEED TO STOP DOING
THAT THANKS THANK YOU SENATOR
NELSON SENATOR NELSON IS
OBJECTING TO THE MOTION CENTER
HERS BERG IS ASKING FOR AN I.
VOTE SENATOR NELSON IS ASKING
FOR NO VOTE. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS FIVE
BABIES NO BACKER FIVE FORGES NO
BRADFORD HI COME BY ADAM HI
WHAT HAS HE- I DALLY NO DODD.
HI THERE ARE SO HI ADNAN HI
BLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES HIGH
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG. I WEST SO
HI HER TADO HI JONES NO
CAMCORDER HI LAYERED I LLEVA.
BY THE MON I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MEN HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH. NO
TAN HI FORTUNE TINO FIVE ROTH
HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. HI STERN
HI I'M BERG HI WHITE HOUSE V.
I. WINNER. WELK NO. HIGHS
THIRTY KNOWS NINE THE MOTION
PASSES- SIR SEARCH FOR THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE PULL THE
FOLLOWING BILL FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE IN ROOM ONE
EIGHTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
FIVE EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FLORIDA THANK YOU THE CENTERS
FOR EXCELLENCE. CENTRE RIGHT
KELSEY. YES MR PRESIDENT ON
BEHALF OF THE AUTHOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHILD PLEASE
REMOVE AB FOUR SEVEN THREE FILE
ITEM ONE FOURTEEN AND FOR AN
EIGHTY FOUR SEVEN FOUR FILE
ITEM- ONE ONE FIVE FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THANK YOU SIR
BYE CASKEY. YEAH MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION PURSUANT TO
JOINT RULE THIRTY THREE POINT
ONE JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE WILL
BE SUSPENDED TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE. TO
MEET AN REPORT MEASURES AFTER
THE POLICY DEADLINE THIS
REQUEST HAS BEEN APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE. STILL
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
SENATOR MELINDA'S. WHAT PURPOSE
DO RICE SAID THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE TWENTY EIGHT AND
MAKE A MOTION TO WITHDRAW SCR
FIVE FROM THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE. NEVER BROUGHT TO THE
FLOOR SO WE CAN HAVE A FULL AND
VIGOROUS DEBATE. SENATORS IT
HAS BEEN FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
TWO DAYS NOW. SINCE THE
DECLARED STATE OF EMERGENCY FOR
KEVIN. YESTERDAY THE GOVERNOR
WAS ASKED ABOUT RE IMPLEMENTING
KEVIN NINETEEN RESTRICTIONS AND
HE SAID IF WE CONTINUE TO GET
PEOPLE VACCINATED THEN THAT
WOULD BE UNNECESSARY. SO AGAIN
I WOULD POINT OUT THAT EVERYONE
WHO WANTS A VACCINE CAN GET ONE
IN MORE THAN TWENTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS HAVE DONE SO FAR
SO IF YOU FOLLOW THE SCIENCE.
THEN YOU KNOW THE VACCINE IS
NINETY THREE PERCENT- EFFECTIVE
IN PREVENTING HOSPITALIZATION
WHICH WAS THE WHOLE POINT OF
THE SHUT DOWN SO THEIR
HOSPITALS DIDN'T GET
OVERWHELMED. AND MORE GOOD NEWS
THE LATEST HOSPITALIZATION
FIGURES IT'S 94% LOWER THAN IT
WAS DURING THE PEAK OF THE
PANDEMIC SO. THERE DOESN'T
APPEAR TO BE IN NEED TO
CONTINUE THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
IT'S BEEN FOUR HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY TWO DAYS AND I THINK
IT'S TIME AND I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR
MELINDA CENTERS CENTER MONDAYS
HAS A MOTION TO WITHDRAW SCR
FIVE FROM GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE CENTER
EXPERT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT THE MAJORITY OR ASK
FOR A NO VOTE MAJORITY LEADER
US FOR A NO VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG
CENTER MELENDEZ IS ASKING FOR
AN I. VOTE. CENTER HERZBERG
VERY CLEARLY IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN NO ARCHULETA- NO
ATKINS NO BABIES. I BACKER. NO
PORCHES HI BRADFORD NO BY ADAM
NO CORTESE. NO DALLY HI TODD.
NO THEY'RE AWESOME NO EGGMAN NO
GLAZER. NO GONZALEZ NO GROWTH
HI HURTS BERG. NO WAY SO. NO NO
HER TADO. NO JONES HI CAN
LONGER NO LAYERED NO LLEVA. NO
THE MOUNT. NO MCGUIRE NO
MELINDA'S BY MEN. NO NEWMAN. NO
NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF BOTH HI
TAM. NO FORTUNE TINO NO RALPH.
NO RUBIO. NO SKINNER. NO STERN
NO- BURKE. NO WAY CASKEY NO
WINNER. WELK HI. HI IS IT NINE
KNOWS THIRTY THE MOTION FAILS.
MEMBERS MOVING ON TO THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE WILL GO TO THE SECOND
READING FILE SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION
FOR SENATE BILL THREE HUNDRED.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY SIX
OF AMENDMENTS EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
WITH AMENDMENTS EIGHT FIFTEEN
WITH AMENDMENTS ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX FORTY WITH AMENDMENTS
SIX NINETY FOUR WITH THE MAN
RUNNING WILL BE DEEMED RED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO- GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. ITEMS TWENTY SIX
THROUGH THIRTY SENATOR LAYERED
WILL BE PRESENTING. ON ITEM
TWENTY SIX FIRST. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT FILE
ITEM TWENTY SIX IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF LIANE RANDOLPH
AS CHAIR OF THE ERROR RESOURCE
RORY READ SOURCES PORT. PRIOR
TO THIS APPOINTMENT MISS
RANDOLPH SERVED AS A
COMMISSIONER OF THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION SHE WAS
DEPUTY SECRETARY AND GENERAL
COUNSEL AT THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY AND SHE ALSO
PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS CHAIR OF
THE FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION. FOR APPOINTMENT WAS
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON MAY TWENTY SIXTH
ON A FIVE OH VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. THANK YOU SHARE LEARN
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE CENTER
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
MIS. READ OFF TO THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD BUT I DO
SHOW. AND RAISING SOME GREAT
CONCERNS AS TO. THE OVERSIGHT
AND MANAGEMENT OF SUCH AGENCY.
AND I'M EXCITED ABOUT HER
SKILLS THAT SHE BRINGS I'VE HAD
OPPORTUNITY WORK WEATHER OVER
THE YEARS WITH PC COMMISSION.
SO I KNOW SHE'S A SKILLED AND
DEDICATED. ADMINISTRATOR BUT
I'M ALSO TROUBLED BY THE AUDIT
THAT WAS REQUESTED THAT I
REQUESTED LAST YEAR HE CAME
BACK EARLY THIS YEAR. AND IT
WAS SKATING AT BEST. AS TO. THE
BLATANT DISREGARD. FOR
DIVERSITY NOT ONLY IN THE
WORKPLACE BUT IN OPINION SO I'M
EXCITED TO SEE ME THROUGH IT
OFF AS THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN. TO OVERSEE THIS POOR
BUT I HOPE IT'S NOT A TOKEN
APPOINTMENT I HOPE SHE'S
ALLOWED TO DO THE SUBSTANTIVE
CHANGES THAT ARE NEEDED IN SUCH
AGENCY AS STATED IN THE AUDIT
EARLIER THIS YEAR. AUDIT THAT
CLEARLY STATED IT DISREGARDED
PEOPLE OF COLOR OPINION BUT
IT'S A AGENCY THAT CONTINUES TO
PICK UP BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES IN POOR COMMUNITIES
FOR MOST OF THE FUNDS THAT THEY
GET EVERY YEAR AND VERY RARELY
DOES ANY OF THESE PROGRAMS IN
DOLLARS EVER REACH THIS
COMMUNITY. SO I HOPE WE STAND
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF HER OF
CHANGING THE CULTURE. AT CAR.
AGENCY THAT IS IN DIRE NEED OF
REAL IMPLEMENTATION A- AGENCY
THAT TOLD ME LAST YEAR THE
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY. FOR POOR
PEOPLE WAS A ZERO EMISSION CAR.
LAUGHABLE AT BEST NOT UNTIL
ELECTRIC CARS BECOME THE TOOLS
OF TE WORKING PEOPLE SO THE
TOYS OF THE RICH WE EVER HAVE
FULL ADOPTION SO I HOPE AGAIN
WITH THE APPOINTMENT OF MR
RUDOLPH WE WILL SEE. GREATER
DIVERSITY NOT ONLY IN THE
WORKPLACE IN THE WORK FORCE BUT
IN OPINION AND THOUGHT AS WELL
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR BRADFORD CENTER
WAY SO. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
SENATORS SIGH I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS APPOINTMENT IT'S
WONDERFUL. TO PUT A PERSON OF
COLOR IN A POSITION SO
IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE OFTEN TIMES THE ONES THAT.
ARE THE- OF THE VICTIMS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL INJUSTICE-
COMMUNITIES THAT TEND TO LIVE
IN SOME OF THE MOST
CONTAMINATED- PEOPLE THAT LIVE
CONTAMINATED COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I HAVE WORKED
WITH- MISS RANDOLPH THREW IN
HER ROLE OF PC AND I CAN I CAN
TELL YOU YOU. THIS IS THE RIGHT
PERSON FOR THE JOB. SHE'S AN
INTELLIGENT HARDWORKING
INDIVIDUAL THAT- HAS-
CALIFORNIA FIRST AND FOREMOST
IN HER MIND IN HER DUTIES.
SHE'S GONNA FIGHT FOR THE
PEOPLE OF OUR STATE. AND I URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES FOR THIS
IMPORTANT APPOINTMENT THAT'S
GOING TO DO SO MUCH IN
IMPROVING CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU SIR MR
CENTER MY CASKEY. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I HAD A RECENT
OPPORTUNITY WERE A COUPLE OTHER
MEMBERS TO TALK TO MISS.
RANDOLPH ABOUT THE APPOINTMENT
AND I SHARED WITH HER SOME OF
MY CONCERNS ON THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM HAS BEEN RUNNING
I KNOW THE- ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ALLIANCE. PARTICIPATED
AS WE DID IN THE- TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SCOPING PLANNING AND
THEY SENT A LETTER. OBJECTING
TO THE FACT THAT NONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE
INCORPORATED THE SCOPING PLAN.
AND WE HAD A- VERY POSITIVE
DISCUSSION BECAUSE THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR A NEW CHAIR TO
COME IN AND NOT NECESSARILY
PIPIT BUT MAKE SOME. CHANGES IN
THE OPERATION I RECEIVED FROM-
SECTOR BLUMENFELD. THIRTEEN
MONTHS AGO A LETTER- PROFESSING
HER INDICATING THAT HE WOULD
WORK WITH CARP LEADERSHIP IN
ORDER TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE
THAT CHANGED THE STATE'S
CLIMATE STRATEGY. THAT WE DON'T
RELY SO MUCH ON CAP AND TRADE
WHAT WE ACTUALLY CHANGE CAP AND
TRADE SO THAT THE FLOOR PRICE
IS NOT EIGHTEEN DOLLARS AND
SOME CHANGE. BUT CLOSE TO THE
FORTY ONE DOLLARS WHICH IS
WHICH IS WHAT THE- COST THE
POLLUTION IS YOU KNOW WE MAY
NOT WANT WANT TO PAY MORE MONEY
BUT BUT THE PROGRAM RUNS. AS
THE AS THE PRO IN ORDER TO
FORCE BEHAVIOR TO CHANGE AND
ALSO TO ALL THE BENEFITS IN
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES WERE THE-
CALL THESE GOING TO GOING TO
IMPROVE. I WAS DELIGHTED TO
HAVE HER RESPOND THAT SHE
SHARES MY ENTHUSIASM THAT
CALIFORNIA MUST. PUT SOME MONEY
OR SOME. OFF INTO THE CLIMATE
AMBITIONS THAT WE SO WE STAYED
YOU KNOW I'M I VOTED FOR EVERY
BILL THAT HAS COME UP HERE THAT
SAYS WE WANT TO DO THIS IN
TWENTY FORTY FIVE WANT TO DO
THIS IN TWENTY THIRTY. BUT SHE
SAID NOT SYMBOLS TYPE OF PERSON
AND I FEEL CONFIDENT THAT SHE'S
GOING TO LISTEN TO THE SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT THE SENATE
HAS FOR YEARS AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMUNITY
HAS. FOR YEARS AND MAKE THESE
PROGRAMS PERFORM THE WAY THAT
THEY ARE IN WE TALKED AT LENGTH
ABOUT THE STATE OF WASHINGTON
WHICH HAS THEIR OWN CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM AND THEY
CRITICIZE. CALIFORNIA AND WE
KNOW ON TYRAEL LEFT OUR OUR
MARKET BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T
SATISFIED THEIR ENVIRONMENTAL-
MISTER I GUESS IT WOULD BE
RAISED SOME POINTS O. THERE'S
A LOT OF WORK TO DO- HI
INCREASE THE CALL IN THE LETTER
THAT THE SECRETARY'S GIVEN US
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH. MISS RANDOLPH- AND THE
AIRPORT STAFF COOPERATIVELY SO
THAT WE COULD MAKE CALIFORNIA
THAT BEACON OF CLIMATE AMBITION
THAT WE ALL BELIEVE WE ARE BUT
PERHAPS. HAS BEEN- FILLING US
IN SOME DETAIL SO I URGE YOU TO
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER BY CAL
SKI ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING NONE CENTER
LAYERED WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT- I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS. OF MY COLLEAGUES ON
THIS. OUR CONFIRMATION- THIS
WAS AN EXCEPTIONALLY LONG
HEARING IN FRONT OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE. AND MANY OF THESE
ISSUES WERE RAISED DIRECTLY AT
THE TIME AND I THINK WORD
KNOWLEDGE IN A GOOD WAY. AND
HONORED BY THE PERSON THAT WE
ARE. WE ARE CONSIDERING FOR
CONFIRMATION SHE FACED THE SAME
ISSUE ABOUT CULTURAL CHANGE
WHEN SHE WAS APPOINTED TO THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
AND SHE WORKED DILIGENTLY
DURING HER TERM. TO ADDRESS
INTERNAL ISSUES THAT WERE LONG
SINCE- IGNORED AND TRY TO MAKE
A DIFFERENCE AND I THINK IT
CLEARLY GIVES HER THE SKILL.
AND THE ABILITY TO DO THE SAME
THING AT KERR. AND I BRUSHED IT
BY QUICKLY THAT SHE SERVED FOR
FOUR YEARS AS THE GENERAL
COUNSEL OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY I RECRUITED
HER. AND SHE WAS REALLY STRONG
WHETHER IT WAS WORKING WITH THE
TRIBES OF WHETHER IT WAS TAKING
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS THAT
WEREN'T NECESSARILY LEGAL AND
WORKING ON THEM THERE. AND SHE
HAD A BACKGROUND AS AN
ASSISTANT TO RETURN A GOVERNOR
WILL MCCARTHY AS AN ATTORNEY IN
PRIVATE PRACTICE AS A CITY
ATTORNEY AS CHAIR OF THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION.
AS WELL AS THE P. YOU SEE THE
NATURAL AND THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY SHE IS ONE OF
THE MOST QUALIFIED PEOPLE WE
WILL EVER CONSIDER. TO BE CHAIR
OF THE CARDBOARD AND SHE IS
THERE AT THE RIGHT TIME I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I.
PHONE. THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
AT KINS I BASE. BECKER HI
FORGES NO BRADFORD I KERR BY
ADAM HI COURTESY FIVE DALLY NO
DOT. HI THERE ALSO HI ADNAN HI
BLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES HIGH
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI WEST SO HI
HER TADO HI JONES NO CAMCORDER
I LAYERED HI LABOUR HI THE MON.
HI MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO MAN.
HI NEWMAN HI NIELSEN NO A SHOW
OF BOTH. NO TEN. FIVE FOURTEEN
TINA HI ROB HI RUBIO HI SKINNER
HI STERN HI AMBERG I Y. CASKEY
I WINNER. WELL. NOW PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BASED GROVE.
WEINER HIGHS THIRTY NO SEVEN
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MOVING
ON TO- FILE I'M TWENTY SEVEN
CENTER LAYERED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR PRESIDENT FIRELIGHT OF
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR JOHN
PAUL NICE TO THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD HE HAS SERVED ON THE
BOARD SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
HE'S A PROFESSOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
AND A PROFESSOR OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH SCIENCES
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY SCHOOL OF PUBLIC
HEALTH HE WAS APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON JUNE NINTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU SIR LET ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
APPOINTMENT. SEEING NONE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS FIVE
BABIES. NO BACKER. HI FORGES NO
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
COURTESY HI DALLY NO DOT. HI
THERE ALSO HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER.
HI CONSOLIDATES HI GROSS NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
HI JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA. HI RAMON I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO MEN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A TRIO OF
BOTH. NO TEN FIVE FOURTEEN TINA
HI RALPH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER I
STERN HI AMBERG HI WHITE HOUSE
SKI FIVE WINNER. WELL NOW.
HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS NINE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MOVING
ON TO ITEM TWENTY EIGHT CENTER
EARLIER THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
FILE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF THE VEENA HURT
TO THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD MIS
HEARD SERVES AS THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE BAY
AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT SHE IS AN ATTORNEY AND
SHE HAS BEEN A BELMONT CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN HE WAS APPROVED BY THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON JUNE
NINTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. PHONE. THANK YOU SIR
LAYERED ON ITEM TWENTY EIGHT
SENATOR BECKER. THANK YOU
MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF BEING HURT AND SHE'S
BEEN A LONG TIME FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE SHE CURRENTLY SERVES
ON THE COUNCIL IN BELMONT IN MY
DISTRICT HE'S ALSO SERVED AS
THE REPRESENTATIVE THE BEER-
THE AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT BOARD WHICH HE CHAIRS
THE EQUITY. ACCESS AND
INCLUSION COMMITTEE. SHOULD BE
A THOUGHTFUL EXPERIENCE VOICE
ON CARBON ONE IN FAVOR OF
EQUITY AND JUSTICE IN THE
CLIMATE SEVERE. SEIZURES AND
MANY REGIONAL BOARD SHE'S A
TEAM PLAYER A THOUGHTFUL AND
CONSIDERATE COLLEAGUE. I'M
CONFIDENT SHE'LL BE AN ASSET TO
CARBON RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU SIR BECKER
ANY DISK ANY OTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
HI AT KINS FIVE BASE NO BECKER
HI FORTUS NO BRADFORD. I HAVE A
HI CORTESE. HI DALLY NO DOT. HI
THERE ALSO HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER
FIVE DOLLARS HI GROSS NO
HERTZBERG HI WEST SO. HI FOR
TIDO HI JONES NO CAMEL UNDER. I
LAYERED I LABOR HI THE MON. I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO MEN. HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN NO A CHILL UP
BOTH NO PAM HI FOURTEEN TO NO.
HI RALPH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER HI
STERN I AM BERG I WAKE OWSKI
FIVE WINNER. WELK NOW. HIGHS
THIRTY KNOWS NINE THE POINT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING ON TO A FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE CENTER LAYERED
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE IS A
CONFIRMATION OF GIDEON CRACK
OFF TO THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
MR CRACKED OFF SERVES AS THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT HE PREVIOUSLY SERVED
AS CHAIR OF THE STATE MINING
AND GEOLOGY BOARD AND CHAIR OF
THE INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANEL AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JUNE NINTH ON A
UNANIMOUS FIVE OH VOTE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS APPOINTMENT SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE KING YEAH MR
PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
FIVE MISTER ACT KRAKOW I HAD
THE PLEASURE TO WORK WITH HIM
WHEN HE WAS CHEERING THE
INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANEL MANY
IF YOU RECALL LAST WEEK WE PASS
THE D. T. S. C. REFORM BILL
THIS THOSE OF MANY OF THE IDEAS
AND THE CHANGES THAT HAVE
OCCURRED TO DGSE OVER THE LAST
FOUR YEARS WE'RE WITH THE WORK
OF THIS- THIS PANEL THANK
LESLIE. THEY TRAVELED ALL OVER
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEY
HAD HEARINGS THEY HAD REPORTS
TODAY THE ENVIRONMENT CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT THAT TIME WE HAD
TWENTY HEARINGS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE I FOUND HIM
KNOWLEDGEABLE DETAILED AND
RESPONSIVE TO THE TO THE
QUESTIONS THAT THE SENATORS
WERE ASKING I WOULD URGE YOU TO
VOTE THANK YOU SIR MY CAST ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS FIVE
BABIES HI BECKER I FORGES NO
BRADFORD HI BECAUSE I HAD A- HI
COURTESY HI DALLY I DONT. HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN. FIVE GLAZER
HI CONSOLIDATES HI GROSS. HI
HERTZBERG FIVE WEST SO. HI
TANTO HI JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. HI LLEVA. FIVE THE MON.
FIVE MCGUIRE. HI HI MELINDA'S.
NO MAN HI NEWMAN HI NIELSEN NO
A SHOW OF BOTH. PAM HI FORTUNE
TINO HI RALPH HI RUBIO. HI
SKINNER HI STERN HI AM BERG. HI
BY CASKEY I WINNER WELL HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BUT SHOW UP BOTH. WEINER THE.
HIGHS THIRTY FOUR KNOWS FOR THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED OR
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
WHICH WILL BE OUR FINAL
GOVERNMENT APPOINTED GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE TODAY CENTER ALERT
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT FILE
ITEM THIRTY IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF TONYA PACHECO WARNER TO THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD MS PAT
CZECHO WARNER SERVICES THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT SHE IS THE
SISTER AND CO DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY HEALTH POLICY
INSTITUTE AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY FRESNO SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JUNE NINTH ON A
UNANIMOUS FIVE OVERLOOKED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR LEHRER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
APPOINTEE SENATOR HER TADO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT TODAY I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE APPOINTMENT OF
DR TALKING ABOUT CHUCK WARNER-
TO THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD DR TYING A PROTECTIVE
ORDER LIVES IN MY HOMETOWN OF
SINGER. AND HAS BEEN VERY
INVOLVED IN OUR COMMUNITY SHE
HAS FIRST HAND KNOWLEDGE OF THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN PUBLIC
HEALTH AND AIR QUALITY AND HAS
STUDIED HOW THE RELATIONSHIPS
OF NEIGHBORHOODS. WHERE SOMEONE
LIVES CAN IMPACT FUTURE HEALTH
OUTCOMES. HAVING SOMEONE WHO
UNDERSTANDS THE IMPACT AIR
QUALITY CONDITIONS HAVE ON THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. WHO IS AN
ADVOCATE AS WELL AS A HEALTH
POLICY RESEARCHER. IS AND THAT
IS AVAILABLE TO MY DISTRICT BUT
ALSO TO THE STATE WHICH IS WHY
I'M URGING AND I VOTE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR TO AUTO
CENTER I CASKEY. A MISTER
PRESIDENT IRAQ ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF DOCTOR OF CHECK
WARNER AND I. WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO PAUSE IT WE HAVE HAD
WITH THIS PHOTO WE WILL HAVE.
SIX ECHO CHANGE THE SEATS OF
FIVE MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
AIR BOARD. AGAIN THE WORLD
LOOKS TO CALIFORNIA ON AIR
QUALITY AND THE CHANGES THAT WE
CAN MAKE IN PUBLIC POLICY. IT'S
A TREMENDOUS TURNOVER OF
LEADERSHIP THERE BUT I'M FILLED
WITH HOPE AND OPPORTUNITY THAT
THAT. THE NECKS THIS TERM OF
FOUR YEARS TO THESE FOLKS WILL
BE- SERVING WILL SEE SOME
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGES IN THE
OPERATION AND IMPROVEMENT WE'RE
DOING A GOOD JOB. BUT IT'S
GOING TO BE IMPROVEMENT
BECAUSE- WITH. OURS
CONSTITUENTS THE PEN UPON IT
AND I WOULD URGE YOU NOT VOTE.
THANK YOU SARAH CASKEY SENATOR
GROVE. THANK YOU MR I TO RISE
IN FAVOR OF- DOCTOR PARTICULAR
WARNER YOU KNOW INTERVIEWING
HER IN TALKING TO HER SHE'S
ACTUALLY VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. SHE UNDERSTANDS
BALANCE BETWEEN MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE CLEAN AIR FOR
CONSTITUENTS BUT ALSO.
INDIVIDUALS THAT PRODUCE FOOD
FOR ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS TO
EAT. AND SHE'S MET WITH A LOT
OF- DIVERSE PEOPLE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHEN I TALK
ABOUT EITHER ITS CORPORATIONS
ARE BUSINESS AND FARMERS TO THE
SMALL FARMERS. AND SHE'S ALSO
MET WITH FARM WORKERS AND SHE'S
TRYING TO BRING A BALANCED
APPROACH. TO THE- AIR RESOURCES
BOARD AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER GROVE ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CONVINCE
ME SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BASE I BECKER I FORGES
HI BRADFORD. HI BYRON HI
QUARTET THE HI DALLY. DODD HI
THERE ALSO HI EGGMAN. I GLAZER
HI GONZALEZ HI GROSS. HI HURTS
BERG HI WITH SO- I HER TADO HI
JONES. CAMCORDER I LAYERED HI
LLEVA HI THE MON HI MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MEN ARE HI NEWMAN I
NELSON. A CHILL OF BOTH. HI PAM
FIVE PORTS TINO HI ROTH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER HI STERN I AM
BERG HI WHITE HOUSE SKI. HI
WINNER. WELL. HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLY JONES.
MELINDA'S NIELSEN. WEINER.
HIGHS THIRTY FIVE KNOWS ZERO
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
THANK YOU CENTER LAYERED FOR
PRESENTATIONS MEMBERS WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS WE HAVE TWO ITEMS
UNDER WHAT UNFINISHED BUSINESS
ITEM FORTY ONE AND ITEM FORTY
TWO WE'RE GONNA GO FIRST ITEM
FORTY ONE SENATOR RUBIO S. B.
ELEVEN. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN BY SENATOR
RUBIO AN ACT RELATING TO
INSURANCE AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE OF SECRET TO
MEDIATE LEE CENTER RUBIO. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY
WE HAVE BEFORE U. S. B. ELEVEN
WHICH IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
SINCE WE LAST SAW THIS BILL
HERE ON THIS FLOOR WE HAVE
ADDED AN EMERGENCY CLAUSE
BECAUSE THIS IS HOW CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. IS TO AN INDUSTRY IN
ORDER FOR CALIFORNIA TO REMAIN
THE BREAD A BASKET OF THE WORLD
WE HAVE TO SUPPORT AND PROTECT
OUR FARMERS AND FARM WORKERS IN
THE FACE OF UNPRECEDENTED
WILDFIRES. I HAVE HEARD SO MANY
STORIES FROM OUR FARMERS AND
OUR GROWERS AND THE
DIFFICULTIES THEY'VE HAD IN
OBTAINING INSURANCE. IN HE
FACE OF UNPRECEDENTED
WILDFIRES- THE WILDFIRE SEASONS
ARE GETTING LONGER MORE
DEADLIER.AND MORE DANGEROUS
AND SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE TAKE CARE OF THIS ISSUE.
WITHOUT INSURANCE FARMERS
CANNOT ACCESS LOANS TO UPDATE
EQUIPMENT- PLANT THEIR CROPS
ARE PAID WORKERS ESPECIALLY IN
A TIME WHEN THEY NEED IT THE
MOST. S. B. ELEVEN IS A GOOD
STEP TOWARDS HELPING A CRITICAL
PART OF OUR STATE'S ECONOMY AND
HELP IN AN INDUSTRY THAT IS
TRYING TO OVERCOME. ESCALATING
RISKS DUE TO WILDFIRES. IT WILL
HELP CLOSE THE COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE COVERAGE GAPS THAT
ARE LEAVING. OUR FARMERS
EXPOSED TO MAJOR LOSSES. THIS
BILL. WILL ALLOW FARMERS
FARMERS RANCHERS AND GROWERS TO
PURCHASE COMMERCIAL INSURANCE
FROM THE FAIR PLAN JUST LIKE
ANY OTHER BUSINESS IN THE
STATE. IN ADDITION THIS WILL
REQUIRE. THE FAIR PLAN TO FILE
A RATE APPLICATION INCLUDING
THIS COVERAGE WITHIN NINETY
DAYS OF THE EFFECTIVE DATE.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
IS SUPPORTED BY A BROAD
COALITION OF THE FARM INDUSTRY
INSURANCE TRADES AND THE FAIR
PLAN AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO SENATORS SENATOR
RUBIO'S ASKING US TO CONCUR AS
SIMPLY AMENDMENTS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
DALLY. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT AS A
FARMER I'VE HEARD FROM MY
NEIGHBORS- THE URGENCY IS
DEFINITELY NEEDED BECAUSE THE
PLANS ARE GOING TO BE WRITTEN
OR NOT WRITTEN. AND THIS WILL
MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE I JUST OR
ENCOURAGE THE URGENCY TO GET
OUT OF HERE ON A UNANIMOUS.
ROLL CALL VOTE. THE CENTRE
DELHI SENATOR DOT. I APPRECIATE
THAT THIS THIS BILL IT'S SORELY
NEEDED I DO WANT TO PUT THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE AND
ALSO THE FAIR PLAN ON NOTICE
THAT A HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS TO
WAIT A HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS TO
GET THIS GOING MAY BE TOO
LITTLE TOO LATE. SO WHILE THIS
IS A OUTSTANDING BILL A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION- IT
FRANKLY THE LEGISLATURE COULD
HAVE DONE IT ANY QUICKER THAN
WE HAVE AND I APPRECIATE THE
BILL'S AUTHOR HERE BUT I WOULD
HOPE THAT THE DEPARTMENT ADD
THEIR FAIR PLAN ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON IT THOSE DAYS THAT
THEY NEED TO- DO WHATEVER THEY
NEED TO DO TO GET THIS. DONE
ARE ALREADY- YEP A PART OF THE
TIME THAT THE LEGISLATURE TOOK
THIS UP WHICH I BELIEVE- IN
THE- SET IN THE SENATE WAS.
BACK IN APRIL SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD SENATOR
HUESO. JUST SIMPLY ON THE BILL
AND THE AMENDMENTS- I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR MOVING
SO QUICKLY ON THIS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WAS LITERALLY
BEGUN THIS YEAR. AND DIE I
ACTUALLY- I DIDN'T THINK WE'D
WE'D ACTUALLY ACHIEVE IT THIS
YEAR AND SO WE REALLY WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING SO
HARD ON THIS. THIS IS GONNA
HELP FULFILL A PROMISE TO-
THESE FARMERS THAT HAVE BEEN-
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY OUR
WILDFIRES AND HOPEFULLY- THOUGH
GOOD COVERAGE- IN TIME FOR. THE
NEXT DISASTER THANK YOU AND I
HOPE THAT THE NEXT DISASTER
NEVER COMES. BUT HOPEFULLY
THEY'LL BE COVERED ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER AND THANK YOU TO THIS
BODY I URGE BIRCH AND I THOUGHT
THANK YOU SIR WEI SO SENATOR
RUBIO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I JUST THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR COMMENTS AND I ASK FOR
MICHAEL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO- VOTING ON IS
SIMPLY AN IMMENSE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA. I. ATKINS. I BASE HI
BACKER. HI OR JUST HI BRADFORD
I HAVE A I DON'T I COURTESY HI
DALLY. I DONT HI THERE ALSO HI
AIKMAN HI PLEASE SIR HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH. HI
HURTS BURKE HI WEST SO HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. HI LLEVA. HI THE MON I
REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S BY MEN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF
BOTH HI TAM. HI FORTUNE TINO.
HI RALPH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER I
STERN HI AMBERG HI WHITE HOUSE
SKI FIVE WINNER. WILKE HI.
HIGHS THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TWO SENATOR GONZALES
FOR ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TWO EIGHTY THREE BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ AN ACT
RELATING TO INSURANCE CENTER
CONSOLES THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I RISE TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
TWENTY THREE WHICH IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE WITH ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS AS B. TWO EIGHTY
THREE MAKES CLARIFYING AND
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THE EQUAL
INSURANCE H. I. V. ACTIVE
TWENTY TWENTY WHICH PROHIBITED
INSURERS. FROM DECLINING AN
INSURANCE APPLICATION OR
ENROLLMENT SOLELY BASED ON A
POSITIVE HIV TEST AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY REPEAL
OUTDATED LANGUAGE REGARDING THE
PROHIBITION ON A POLICY OR
CERTIFICATE FROM LIMITING
BENEFITS PAYABLE FOR A LOSS
CAUSED BY OR CONTRIBUTED. TO BY
HIV OR AIDS THESE CHANGES ARE
CRITICAL IN STRENGTHENING
PROTECTIONS AND ENSURING THE
EQUAL INSURANCE HIV ACT IS
IMPLEMENTED AS IT WAS INTENDED
THINKING I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE ON SB TWO EIGHTY THREE.
THANK YOU CENTER GONZALES ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE MEMBERS
THIS QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NO
OBJECTION THE ITEM PASSES EYES
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO AS-
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. WHAT'S
THE FIRST ITEM OF THE FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY FIVE. AND LET'S. I
BELIEVE SIR CALERO IS
PRESENTING THAT AND SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK SILVA AN ACT RELATING TO
MOBILE HOMES. THEIR CAREER
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE
TO PRESENT AB EIGHT NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYWOMAN QUIRK SILVA
MEMBERS THIS IS A DISTRICT
BUILT FOR IT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THIS BILL BUILDS UPON
THE IMPORTANT POLITY POLICY
DISCUSSIONS THAT TOOK PLACE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN RELATED TO RENT
STABILIZATION AND EXTENDS THOSE
PROTECTIONS TO CERTAIN MOBILE
HOME PARK RESIDENTS MOBILE HOME
OWNERS JUST LIKE TRADITIONAL
HOMEOWNERS PAY MORTGAGE ON THE
HOME. MUST PAY FOR REPAIRS AND
MAINTENANCE AS WELL AS HOME
TAXES BUT UNLIKE THE
TRADITIONAL HOMEOWNERS FAMOUS
ALSO BUDGET FOR RENT EXPENSES
FOR THEIR PERSONAL WITHIN THE
MOBILE HOME PARK JUST AS RENTS
HAVE DRAMATICALLY INCREASED
STATEWIDE MOBILE WHOLE HOME
RESIDENTS ARE ALSO FACING
DRASTIC RENT RENT INCREASES
FROM PARK OWNERS HOWEVER SOME
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS
EXPERIENCE EAD RENT INCOME
INCREASES FIND THEMSELVES IN A
UNIQUE SITUATION IN ONE
PARTICULAR CASE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS IN THE
MOBILE HOME PARK THAT IS IT IS
SPLIT BETWEEN TWO DIFFERENT
CITIES THAT EXPERIENCED BACK TO
BACK. DOUBLE DIGIT RENT
INCREASES THIS BILL SIMPLY
ROUTE LIMITS RENT INCREASES
ONLY FOR THOSE RARE SITUATIONS
IN WHICH A MOBILE HOME PARK IS
LOCATED IN AND GOVERNED BY MORE
THAN ONE INCORPORATED CITY TO
NO MORE THAN 3% ANNUALLY PLUS
THE CPI TO A MAXIMUM OF 5%
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY EIGHT
PROVIDES RELIEF TO THOSE
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS WHO FIND
THEMSELVES. IN THE SITUATION
WHERE THEY HAVE TO DECIDE
WHETHER THEY PAY THE RENT OR
PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU SIR OF
MEMBERS ON FILE AND I'M SEVENTY
FIVE EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY EIGHT
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR NEWMAN. OUR TEAM IS
PRESENT I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE WHICH HAS
BEEN BROUGHT BY MY COLLEAGUE
CHECK WORKS OVER. AND THE-
EXAMPLE THAT MY COLLEAGUE
SHARED ABOUT THE MOBILE HOME
PARK IN WHICH IN MY DISTRICT.
IS A GOOD EXAMPLE OF THE
CHALLENGES IT FACES INDUSTRY
WHERE I QUITE OFTEN THE- PERSON
OWNS THEIR HOME BUT NOT THE NOT
THE PROPERTY UNDERNEATH IT-
THESE WORKING CLASS PEOPLE WHO
ARE OFTEN SUBJECT. TO ALL THE
USUAL PRESSURES BUT BUT
POWERLESS IN THE FACE OF MOBILE
HOME PARK OWNERS. WHO OFTEN
EXPLOIT THEIR NEED. AND THE
FACT THEY HAVE NOWHERE ELSE TO
GO SO I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE COMMEND THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU SIR NEWMAN CENTER
MEANT. FIVE A QUESTION FOR- THE
AUTHOR THE PRESENTER I DON'T
KNOW YOUR MEN WERE IN I THINK
I'VE I'VE I RISE TO ASK A
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR THE
PRESENTER- ANY ANALYSIS AT
CENTER COPYRIGHT WOULD YOU
ACCEPT THE QUESTION. THANK YOU
SO YOU CAN TRACK IT IN THE
FINAL ANALYSIS IT SAYS THAT- ON
PAGE FIVE TO SIX THAT DOES FIT
THE BILL WHILE IT SEEMS CLEAR
THIS INTENDED ONLY TO APPLY A
LAW APPLIES THE RANGE OF
APPLAUSE MOBILE HOME PARK. FIVE
OUR ANALYSIS- DOES NOTE THAT
THIS LIFE WE COULD APPLY TO
OTHER MOBILE HOME PARKS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND ALSO.
THAT THEY COULD IN THEORY APPLY
TO OTHER MOBILE HOME PARKS IN
THE FUTURE THAT MIGHT BE
DEVELOPED- AND THAT IT MIGHT
ALSO RUN AFOUL WITHOUT
AMENDMENTS OF CONSTITUTIONAL
PROVISIONS ON SOCIAL
LEGISLATION I'VE BEEN TALKING
WITH THE AUTHOR OR NOT HI SHE
TELLS ME SHE'S TAKEN AMENDMENTS
I JUST I DON'T KNOW THE STATUS
OF THIS AND THIS THIS KIND OF
CONCERNING. THAT BECAUSE I
BELIEVE INTENT WAS JUST TO
MONITOR THIS ONE PART OF THE
INDUSTRY BUILT YES SENECA YES
TO ANSWER THE QUESTION THIS
DOES RIGHT NOW- PLAYED ONLY ONE
PARK IS AS FAR AS WE KNOW- IT'S
A VERY UNUSUAL SITUATION WHERE
A PARK IS SITUATED IN THE
JURISDICTION OF TWO CITIES WHAT
WE DO IS WE LEAVE IT UP TO THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO DECIDE
WITH THE RULES AND- ARE IN
REGARDS TO RENT INCREASES. AND
WHEN IT WHEN THERE ARE TWO
CITIES YOU CAN HAVE IN- YOU CAN
SEE WHAT YOU CAN HAVE ONE CITY
AGREE IN ONE CITY NOT AGREE AND
THAT BASICALLY LEAVES THE PARK
RESIDENCE- WITHOUT ANY
PROTECTION ANY RENT
STABILIZATION PROTECTIONS SO.
IF THERE IS ANOTHER INSTANCE
WHERE A PARK IS IN TWO
DIFFERENT CITIES THEN IT
OBVIOUSLY WOULD APPLY- BUT NONE
HAVE. BEEN FOUND UP TO THIS
POINT AND I THINK IT'S PROBABLY
HIGHLY UNLIKELY BUT IN THE
EVENT THAT A PARK ENDS UP IN
TWO CITIES THE CITIES THOSE TWO
SEPARATE CITIES CAN AGREE THAT
ONE CITY WILL COME. UP WITH A
SOLUTION AND IN AND IMPOSE IT
ON THE END PARK THAT'S- THE
BILL DOESN'T THE BILL. OF LAW
GOVERNMENT TO MAKE DECISIONS-
IT JUST IT IT IT IT- PROVIDES
AN ALTERNATIVE THAT PROTECTS
THE PARK RESIDENTS WHEN NEITHER
CITY IS ACTING TO DO TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SARAH
CARREIRO SHOW EXCEPT THAT AS
YOU'RE CLOSER YES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
IN A COVER UP. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI I. ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BASE NO BECKER. HI
FORGES NO BRADFORD HI HAVE ADAM
HI CORTESE HI DALLY. DODD HI
THERE ALSO HI ADNAN HI GLAZER.
NO BECAUSE ALL THIS HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI WEST SO. HER TADO
HI JONES. CAN LONGER FIVE
LAYERED HI LABOUR. HI THE MON
FIVE MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S. NO
MAN. NEWMAN HI NIELSEN NO A
SHOW OF BOTH. NO TAN HI FORTUNE
TINO. HI RALPH HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER I STERN I AM BERG I Y.
CASKEY I WINNER. WELL. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. TALLY
GROVE. WAY SO. JONES MANY.
WINNER WELL. HIGHS TWENTY SEVEN
KNOWS- SIX AMENDMENT- THE-
MAJOR PASSES. MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FIGHT HIM ONE OH
TWO WHICH IS A B. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE WE HAVE SENATOR
COM LOGGER FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOW. SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AN
ACT RELATING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
CENTER COME UNDER. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND SENATORS AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE WOULD
PROHIBIT POLICE DEPARTMENTS
FROM POSTING ON SOCIAL MEDIA
THE MUG SHOTS OF PEOPLE
ARRESTED ON SUSPICION OF
COMMITTING A NON VIOLENT CRIME.
IN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
SUSPECTS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
PRESUMED INNOCENT UNTIL PROVEN
GUILTY. BUT IF ANY OF YOU EVER
HEARD HE TESTIFY ON ANY OF MY
BILLS YOU KNOW THIS ISN'T THE
CASE. WHEN A DEPARTMENT
PUBLISHES A PERSON'S MUGSHOT ON
FACEBOOK FOR EXAMPLE WITHOUT
WAITING FOR A CONVICTION OR
EVEN FOR CHARGES. TO BE
FORMALLY FILED THE PUBLIC DOES
RUSH TO JUDGMENT THIS CAN CARRY
GREAT EVEN LIFELONG
CONSEQUENCES FOR THE ACCUSED
THESE POSTS ARE SHARED WITH
FAMILY FRIENDS EMPLOYERS
CAUSING GREAT EMOTIONAL AND
FINANCIAL HARM. WITH A GOOGLE
SEARCH A MUGSHOT ON FACEBOOK
COULD ALLOW COULD FOLLOW A
PERSON FOR LIFE EVEN IF THAT
PERSON WAS ULTIMATELY NOT FOUND
GUILTY. FURTHERMORE THESE
POSTER LITTLE TO WARN THE
COMMUNITY OF AN ONGOING PUBLIC
SAFETY THREAT. AS A SUSPECT IS
ALREADY IN CUSTODY AT THE TIME
OF POSTING. AND POSTING
MUGSHOTS PERPETUATES HARMFUL
STEREOTYPES AND FOSTERS BIAS
WHICH IS WHY THE SAN FRANCISCO
POLICE DEPARTMENT THIS SUMMER
DECIDED TO END THE PRACTICE OF
RELEASING SUSPECTS MUGSHOTS
UNDER MOST CIRCUMSTANCES. THIS
IS NOT A RADICAL STEP THE STATE
OF UTAH RECENTLY VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY TO END THE RELEASE
OF MUG SHOTS BEFORE A PERSON IS
CONVICTED AND THE STATE OF
ILLINOIS RECENTLY PASSED A
NEARLY IDENTICAL LAW TO THIS. I
WANT TO REITERATE THAT THIS
BILL APPLIES ONLY TO NON
VIOLENT CRIMES AND SIMPLY
REAFFIRMS THE PRINCIPLE THAT
THE ACCUSED ARE CONSIDERED
INNOCENT UNTIL PROVEN GUILTY
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU SIR COME LONGER CENTER
BOARD JUST. THE PRESIDENT. I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS ITEM I
THINK IT GOES TO THE HEART OF
OUR- CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
THAT INDIVIDUAL TRULY IS
CONSIDERED INNOCENT UNTIL
PROVEN GUILTY- IN A PERFECT
WORLD THIS WOULD BE EXPANDED-
NOT JUST ON THE SOCIAL MEDIA
FRONT BUT ALSO- THROUGH PRESS
ANNOUNCEMENTS AND OTHER
STATEMENTS. WITH EXCEPTIONS FOR
EXAMPLE OF THOSE THAT MAYBE
HAVE SKIPPED BAIL FOR I HAVE
KICKED OVR ALLEGED TO HAVE
COMMITTED TO HAVE. DANGEROUS
ACTS AND- PUBLIC IS BEING ASKED
FOR INFORMATION TO DEFINE THESE
INDIVIDUALS BUT THE BILL AS IT
STANDS I THINK IS A STRONG STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION OF
ANYONE WHO HAS EVER ASSOCIATED
OR BEFRIENDED FOLKS- HO'VE
BEEN IN THIS SITUATION IT
IMPACTS THEM THEIR FAMILIES
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND WHEN
THEY'RE FOUND INNOCENT AFTER A
PROPER PROCESS THE DAMAGE IS
ALREADY DONE SO WITH THAT- I
ENCOURAGE ALL MY COLLEAGUES TO.
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
SIR FOR JUST ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CENTER
COM LONGER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE AT THANK YOU I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO
FOR HIS COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I'LL VOTE THANK YOU SIR
COME LONGER CENTERS THIS IS
FILE I DON'T WANT. EIGHTY
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW IT QUALIFIES
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NO OBJECTION THE
MAJOR PASSES EYES THIRTY NINE
KNOWS ZERO. MEMBERS THAT WRAPS
UP AS SIMPLY THIRD READING FOR
TODAY. WE ARE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS AND
FOLLOWING THAT WE'LL HAVE A
GERMANS IN MEMORY. COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS WILL RECOGNIZE
SENATOR RUBIO FIRST. CENTER
RUBIO. THANK YOU MR CHAIR OF
THE INSURANCE COMMITTEE WILL
MEET HERE- I WOULD SAY TWENTY
TWENTY MINUTES AFTER WE CLOSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR RUBIO
CENTER CORTESE- THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- I WILL BE CHEERING
OF THE HOUSING COMMITTEE. TODAY
IN THE ABSENCE OF- SENATOR
WIENER AND THAT. WILL TAKE
PLACE AFTER THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE IN THESE CHAMBERS- WE
WILL- CONVENE AS IMMEDIATELY AS
POSSIBLE LET'S ASSUME ABOUT
FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER INSURANCE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR CORTESE WILL TRY TO BE
QUICK AND INSURANCE TO. SENATOR
MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR- GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE WILL BE MEETING IN ROOM
NINE ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
AT ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU
SIR MCGUIRE CENTER STERN YEAH
IS THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SNS RESOURCE IN WATER COMMITTEE
WILL BE MEETING IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE- AT ELEVEN THANK
YOU SIR MR MEMBERS JUST TO
RECAP WE HAVE FOUR COMMITTEES
MEETING AFTER SESSION.
INSURANCE HOUSING. GOVERNMENT
AND FINANCE AND NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER. YEAH HE
DID. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO BE
RECOGNIZING A GERMAN AND GERMAN
IN MEMORY IF IT SAYS DON'T WORK
FOR A PERSON RIGHT. APOLOGIES
AT ANY TO AMEND THE TIMING ON
SEVEN THAT'S RESEARCH IN WATER
IMMEDIATELY UPON ADJOURNMENT
THANK YOU NATURAL RESOURCES I
MEAN UPON A GERMAN FORTY TWO OH
THREE. THANK YOU SIR STERN.
OKAY NOW MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. SECRETARY JOB
SOMETHING ELSE TO ADD TO YOUR
ANNOUNCEMENT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT IF WE CAN BRING
EVERYBODY'S ATTENTION BACK TO
THE FLOOR FOR GERMAN MEMORIES
I'D APPRECIATE THAT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN WE'RE GONNA BEGIN A
GERMAN IN MEMORY IF WE CAN ALL
TAKE OUR SEATS PLEASE AND BRING
PROPER REVERENCE TO THE FLOOR.
FOR THIS IMPORTANT ITEM.
SENATOR SKINNER YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK OU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
OF MY COMMUNITY BERKELEY IS
REELING FROM THE TRAGIC DEATHS
OF TWO OF BERKELEY'S BELOVED
YOUNG ADULTS SIXTY LEWIS AND
RUSSELL WHO WERE KILLED IN A
CAR CRASH ON HIGHWAY EIGHTY
NINE OUTSIDE OF TRUCKEE AT THE
END OF MAY. AS A MOTHER WHEN I
LEARNED ABOUT THAT ACCIDENT THE
HEART ACHE THAT I FELT WAS
PALPABLE BECAUSE THE PAIN OF
LOSING A CHILD WHEN THEY ARE IN
THE PRIME OF THEIR LIFE IS
SOMETHING THAT AS PARENTS IT'S
OUR WE SPEND FROM BIRTH UNTIL
OUR CHILDREN LEAVE OUR HOMES
ARE TRYING TO AVOID THAT AND
YET AS WE ALL KNOW SUCH
TRAGEDIES. OCCUR DIXIE AND ROSS
WERE JUST NINETEEN AND TWENTY
YEARS OLD THEY WERE A COUPLE.
DIXIE HAD JUST FINISHED HER
FIRST YEAR AT CAL POLY POMONA
ROSS WHO JUST COMPLETED HIS
SECOND YEAR SAME SCHOOL. ROSS'S
ANTILOCK DESCRIBED THE COUPLE
AS FUNNY THEY WERE CHARMING
THEY WERE BOTH SMART THEY HAD
FRIENDSHIPS THAT WERE THE
DEEPEST WITH THE MOST
INCREDIBLE BONDS. DIXIE LEWIS
IS THE DAUGHTER OF MICHAEL
LEWIS THE AUTHOR OF MONEYBALL
AND THE BIG SHORT. HER MOTHER
TAP AT THE STORE IN IS A
PHOTOGRAPHER AND FORMER
POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT.
DIXIE'S MOTHER CAPITA DESCRIBES
DIXIE AS A FIGHTER NOT JUST FOR
HERSELF BUT FOR EVERYONE. SHE
EXPLAINED THAT DIXIE HAD A FIRE
WHEN SHE WALKED IN A ROOM THAT
PEOPLE COULD FEEL AND WHEN SHE
SHOWED UP SHE WAS GOING TO SHOW
UP A HUNDRED AND FIFTY PERCENT.
HE LIVED AND LOVED FIERCELY.
DIXIE WAS KNOWN FOR HER PASSION
FOR SPORTS HER VOLUNTEERISM.
AND HER GIVING BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY SHE WAS A SCHOLAR
ATHLETE AND SHE VOLUNTEERED FOR
A SPIRE EDUCATION'S READING
BUDDIES. FROM A YOUNG AGE SHE
WAS A STAR SOFTBALL PLAYER SHE
PLAYED VARSITY ALL FOUR YEARS
WHEN SHE WAS AT BERKELEY HIGH
AND SHE WAS RECRUITED BY CAL
POLY. POMONA TO PLAY SOFTBALL
SHE PLAYED THIRD BASE AND SHE
PLANNED TO MAJOR IN
NEUROSCIENCE. FRIENDS RECALLED
HER IS GENEROUS AND SHE
WELCOMED HER FRIENDS INTO HER
HOME FOR LONG STAYS WHEN THEY
WERE GOING THROUGH HARD TIMES.
HER FATHER MICHAEL LEWIS SAID
OF DIXIE SHE LOVES TO LIVE. OUR
HEARTS ARE SO BROKEN WE CAN'T.
FIND THE WORDS TO DESCRIBE THE
FEELING. MICHAEL NOTED HOW MUCH
HIS DAUGHTER LOVED HER HIGH
SCHOOL SWEETHEART ROSS. RUSH
SHOTS WAS BORN ON VALENTINE'S
DAY IN BERKELEY AND HE WAS
DESCRIBED BY FRIENDS FAMILY
COACHES AS KIND INTELLIGENT FUN
LOVING JOYOUS AND HAVING AN
INFECTIOUS SMILE. ROSS'S FAMILY
WAS A FIXTURE IN BERKELEY HIS
GRANDFATHER THE REVEREND GUY
SCHULTZ WAS A PASTOR OF
BERKELEY'S UNIVERSITY LUTHERAN
CHAPEL. WHICH WAS ONE OF THE
FIRST SANCTUARY CHURCHES AND
HOUSED REFUGEES FROM EL
SALVADOR NICARAGUA HIS FATHER
BART SCHULTZ OWNED AND OPERATED
THE SMALL BUSINESS VITAL SIGNS
WERE ROSS ALSO WORKED IN HIS
MOTHER GINA LAMB WAS THE
DIRECTOR OF BUSINESS OPERATIONS
AT A HEALTH SERVICES COMPANY.
ROSS'S FAMILY REMEMBERS HIM FOR
HIS QUIET MAGNETISM WHICH DREW
MANY FRIENDS AND FAMILIES AND
RELATIVES TO HIM. LIKE DIXIE
ROSS WAS ALSO A SCHOLAR ATHLETE
HE WAS A PASSIONATE SOCCER
PLAYER. HE WAS ON BERKELEY
HEIGHTS TO NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CHAMPIONSHIP SOCCER TEAMS AND
HE PLAYED VARSITY SOCCER CAL
POLY POMONA WHERE HE STUDIED
KINESIOLOGY. ROSS'S FAMILY
RECALLED HOW MUCH THAT HE LOVES
DIXIE. AND SEE HIM THEY WILL
ALWAYS CARRY THE WORDS THE
DIXIE HAD INSCRIBED ON A WALLET
THAT SHE GAVE TO ROSS. IN GOLD
LETTERS ON THAT WALLET IT SAID
DAILY REMINDER THAT I LUCKY.
THESE TWO BELOVED YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO HAD SO MUCH TO GIVE WE'RE
TORN FROM US EARLY. THEY ARE
AND WILL BE DEEPLY MISSED BY
THEIR FAMILIES THEIR FRIENDS
THE COMMUNITY OF BERKELEY THEY
GREW UP IN AND ALL WHO KNEW
THEM. PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
DURING THIS ADJOURNING THIS
SESSION OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE IN THE MEMORY OF DIXIE
LEWIS AND RUSSELL. THANK YOU
SIR SKINNER CENTER TARA. I RISE
TODAY TO TURN IN THE MEMORY OF
EMAILS BACK ASIDE AS SLOAN.
YOUR MOTHER WAS BORN IN THE
VILLAGE OF LOS MICHAEL SAM WHEN
YOU SEE PEOPLE LIKE YOU THAT ME
TRUCK ON ON MARCH TENTH OF
NINETEEN THIRTY SIX. SHE WAS
BORN TO ALREADY GONE UP A SINUS
AND PUT FREEDIA MEDICAL CENTER
WAS THE YOUNGEST OF FIVE
SIBLINGS. IN NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN IMELDA MARRIED TO MY
LOVELY ON A YOUNG MAN FROM THE
VILLAGE HE GREW UP IN. HE
TRAVELED BACK AND FORTH TO
CALIFORNIA TO WORK IN THE
AGRICULTURAL FIELDS TO THE BUS
THAT'LL PROGRAM. SHE SOON
JOINED HIM AT THE ONE WHERE SHE
LIVED WITH AN AUNT AND WHERE
SHE GAVE BIRTH TO THEIR FIRST
SON. AROUND NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE FROM MOTHER WAS ABLE TO
SECURE PERMANENT RESIDENCY IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WAS ABLE TO
BRING HIS YOUNG FAMILY NOW A
FAMILY OF FIVE TO LIVE WITH HIM.
THEIR FAMILIES REMAINING FOUR
CHILDREN WERE BORN IN FRESNO
INCLUDING FIGURE IN THEIR
YOUNGEST SON RAY LEONE NOW
MAYOR OF HURON. HE MET THIS
HOUSE HOSTED MANY RELATIVES AS
THEY WORK TOWARDS THE AMERICAN
DREAM. HER HOUSE WAS THE
LANDING PAD AND THE LAUNCHING
PAD SHE WAS A HARD WORKER AND A
GREAT COOK. HE WOULD MAKE
LUNCHES FOR ALL HER RELATIVES
WHO WORKED IN AGRICULTURE AND
THEN WOULD JOIN THEM WORKING IN
THE FIELDS. LATER SHE MANAGED
THE KITCHEN OF THE FAMILY'S
RESTAURANT HELPING TO MAKE THE
BUSINESS A SUCCESS. IMELDA WAS
ALWAYS THINKING ABOUT FAMILY
ESPECIALLY THE YOUNGER
GENERATIONS. SHE MENTORED MANY
AND RAISE NUMEROUS
GRANDCHILDREN SHE IS SURVIVED
BY SEVEN CHILDREN TEN
GRANDCHILDREN THIRTEEN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. SHE WAS A MOTHER
EIGHTY R. EIGHTY OUT OF ONE
LAST A GRANDMOTHER A GREAT
GRANDMOTHER AND A PILLAR OF HER
COMMUNITY. AND SO WE TAKE THIS
MOMENT TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
YOU MY LOVE. CENTER CAMARO ON
THIS ITEM. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT I WANNA JOIN MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SINGER TO- SHOW
MY APPRECIATION TO A WOMAN WHO
REALLY EMBODIES THE AMERICAN
DREAM WHOSE STORY IS- CAN BE
LOST I THINK IN AND IN MANY
WAYS BECAUSE- THEY IT'S A LIFE
WELLLIVED IT IS BASED ON HARD
WORK. AND THE COMMITMENT TO
PROVIDING THE SUPPORT THAT THE
FAMILY WOULD NEED BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY SHE WAS A WOMAN OF
STRONG CHRISTIAN VALUES AND SHE
BELIEVED- INTIMATELY IN SERVING
NOT ONLY HER FAMILY BUT THE
COMMUNITY AND IN MAKING SURE
THAT SHE LEFT THE WORLD A
BETTER PLACE BECAUSE SHE WAS
SHE WAS HERE- VERY SIMPLE WMAN
FROM VERY HUMBLE BEGINNINGS BUT
SHE WORKED HER ENTIRE LIFE TO
BE ABLE TO CREATE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR HER FAMILY TO
BE SUCCESSFUL. AND THE FACT
THAT HER SON IS NOW THE MAYOR
OF THE COMMUNITY OF HURON
REALLY SPEAKS TO THE COMMITMENT
TO A COMMUNITY SERVICE THE
COMMITMENT TO DOING EVERYTHING
THAT YOU CAN TO BETTER AND LIFT
UP ALL OF THE FAMILIES AND SO
I'M GONNA ASK THIS THIS- AUGUST
BODY TO PLEASE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY. OF A MOTHERLY ON. THANK
YOU SIR CVER OF MOVING ON TO
THE NEXT IN GERMAN MEMORY
SENATOR UMBERG. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES IT'S
WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I RISE
TODAY TO REQUEST THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF A
LONGTIME STATE EMPLOYEE. ORANGE
COUNTY RESIDENT AND WINNINGEST
UCLA PAC TWELVE CONFERENCE
FOOTBALL COACH OF ALL TIME
TERRY DONAHUE. COACHED ON HE
WAS BORN IN LOS ANGELES IN
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR AND
GRADUATED FROM NOTRE DAME HIGH
SCHOOL IN SHERMAN OAKS HE
WASN'T RECRUITED FOR ANY
COLLEGE FOOTBALL TEAM BUT HE
WAS A WALK ON AT SAN JOSE STATE
AND THEN AT LA VALLEY COLLEGE.
AND EVENTUALLY AT UCLA- DESPITE
WINNING ONLY A HUNDRED AND
NINETY POUNDS COACHED ON YOU
PLAYED DEFENSIVE TACKLE FOR TWO
SEASONS WITH THE BROWNS. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE UCLA WAS
PART OF THE UCLA TEAM THAT WON
ITS FIRST ROSE BOWL- FOLLOWING
HIS GRADUATION COACH DONAHUE
BEGAN HIS COACHING CAREER AS AN
ASSISTANT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
KANSAS IN NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE
BECAME AN ASSISTANT AT UCLA.
STARTING IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX AT THE RIPE OLD AGE OF
THIRTY ONE COACH DON WHO BECAME
THE HEAD COACH FOR THE BRUINS
REMAIN HEAD COACH. FOR THE NEXT
TWENTY YEARS DURING POST ON HIS
TENURE HE WOULD GO ON TO BECOME
THE WINNINGEST FOOTBALL COACH-
A- U. N. YOU. HISTORY OUT
THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER HE
COACHED THIRTY FOUR FIRST TEAM
ALL AMERICANS FOURTEEN PLAYERS
SELECT IN THE FIRST ROUND OF
THE NFL DRAFT. HIS TEAMS WON
FOUR PAC TEN. CHAMPIONSHIPS
TIED FOR ANOTHER N. ONE THREE
ROSE BOWLS. FOLLOWING OF WELL
MOST IMPORTANTLY AS A COACH I
HAD A WINNING RECORD AGAINST
USC FOLLOWING HIS USUALLY
FOOTBALL CAREER COACH DONNA YOU
WORKED AS A BROADCASTER IN THE
FRONT OFFICE THE SENSES GO
FORTY NINERS. WITH A SUCCESSFUL
FOUR YEAR STINT AS A GENERAL
MANAGER. TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
COSTA WHO HELPED FOUND
CALIFORNIA SHOWCASE HELD AT THE
GREAT PARK IN IRVINE WHERE HIGH
SCHOOL. JUNIOR AND JUNIOR
COLLEGE STUDENTS FROM
THROUGHOUT. CALIFORNIA TRAINED
AND SHOWCASE THEIR SKILLS FOR
COLLEGE. COACHES LAST SUNDAY
WHILE HIS HOME IN NEWPORT BEACH
COAST ON WHO PASSED AWAY AT THE
AGE OF SEVENTY SEVEN AFTER TWO
YEAR BATTLE WITH CANCER. HE WAS
SURROUNDED BY HIS FAMILY HIS
WIFE OF FIFTY TWO YEARS ANDREA
DAUGHTERS NICOLE MICHELLE
JENNIFER- THREE SONS IN LAW.
AND TEN GRANDCHILDREN- THIS
FALL WHEN YOU SILLY PLACES
FIRST FOOTBALL GAME. I THINK
BRUIN NATION WILL. OBSERVE HIS
MEMORY WITH ITS VERY FIRST AID
CLASS THANK YOU SO WE TURNED
HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU CEREMONY
SENATOR HANSON THEIR PANTS.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- CENTERS
I RISE TO TURN IN MEMORY OF
WILLIAM CLYDE LEWIS SENIOR WHO
PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTY FOUR AT MERCY DIGNITY
HOSPITAL IN SACRAMENTO ON
FATHER'S DAY JUNE TWENTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE MR LEWIS WAS
BORN IN LINDALE TEXAS AND MAY
TWELFTH NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN
HIS FAMILY LATER RELOCATED
SACRAMENTO COREY ATTENDED
STANFORD JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES MCCLATCHY HIGH SCHOOL
IN NINETEEN FIFTY SIX. AFTER
GRADUATING MR LEWIS BEGAN A
FOUR DECADE LONG CAREER IN THE
SERVICE OF THE PUBLIC IN THE US
POSTAL SERVICE BEFORE HIS
RETIREMENT IN NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN. A FAMILY MAN ABOVE ALL
ELSE MR LEWIS ENJOYED A LONG
LOVING PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LATE ELIZABETH ALLEN WHOM HE
MARRIED IN. NINETEEN FIFTY NINE
ENJOYING FIFTY EIGHT YEARS OF
MARRIAGE UNTIL HER PASSING ON
JUNE TWENTY SECOND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. MR LEWIS SERVED AS A
DIRECTOR OF THE PARENTS AND
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION THE SECOND
S. C. UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES AND
SEVENTIES. I WAS ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE SACRAMENTO POLICE
DEPARTMENT CHAPLAINCY. HE WAS A
LIFELONG MEMBER OF THE PLEASANT
HILL MISSIONARY BAPTIST CHURCH
AND SERVED AS CHAIRMAN OF THE
DEACONS BOARD AND TRUSTEE OF
THE CHURCH. MR LEWIS IS ALSO AN
ESTEEMED MEMBER OF THE HIRAM OF
TYRE EAST SAINT PAUL LODGE
CHAPTER FORTY EIGHT WHICH
RECENTLY SO THAT WAS A
SCHOLARSHIP FUND IN HIS HONOR.
AND THANKFULLY MR LEWIS WAS
ABLE TO GIVE THE FIRST ACADEMIC
SCHOLARSHIP AWAY- JUST EARLIER
THIS YEAR ON IT- JUST A FEW
WEEKS BEFORE HIS PASSING. MR
LEWIS IS SURVIVED BY HIS LOVING
FAMILY INCLUDING HIS SISTER AND
THREE BROTHERS HIS SON AND TWO
DAUGHTERS AS WELL HIS
GRANDCHILDREN AND GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. TODAY WE JOIN
THEM TO REMEMBER AND CELEBRATE
WILLIAM CLYDE LEWIS SENIOR
FIRST OIL SERVICE TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND WE SEND OUR
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO HIS
FAMILY AND FRIENDS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE TURN
IT IS MEMORY THANK YOU. THANK.
YOU CENTER PANS SENATOR DURAZO.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT. MEMBERS
I RISE TO ASK THAT WE ADJOURNED
IN THE MEMORY OF WHOLE SET THE
MAS MAY HEAR. A DECADES LONG
MEMBER OF SEIU U. S. W. W. WHO
WAS TRAGICALLY MURDERED ON JUNE
SIXTEENTH WHILE AT WORK. OVER
THE PAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS
THOMAS WAS A STRONG LEADER OF
THE UNION REPRESENTING
JANITORS. AND SECURITY OFFICERS
AND SERVING ON THE SEIU
EXECUTIVE BOARD. AFTER HAVING
ENDURED THE HARD AND DANGEROUS
JOURNEY OF MIGRATING FROM EL
SALVADOR. HE FOUND WORK AS A-
AS A JANITOR AT TOYOTA. HE WAS
THERE HE FIRST GOT INVOLVED IN
THE UNION ORGANIZING HIS
COWORKERS TO WIN UNION
RECOGNITION. AND BECOMING PART
OF AN EMPLOYER'S MASTER
CONTRACT. FOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. HE FOREVER CHANGED THE
STRENGTH OF THEIR UNION. HE WAS
ALWAYS LOOKING OUT FOR
EVERYONE'S WELL BEING. IN
ADDITION HE ALSO SERVED AS A
MEMBER OF THE SCO YOU FINANCE
COMMITTEE TAKING RESPONSIBILITY
FOR HIS LOCAL UNIONS FINANCIAL
SUSTAINABILITY. MR MAN HEE OUT
WAS ALSO A COMPOSITING THAT IS.
A PEER TO PEER ADVOCATE IN THE
YEP US THE CENTER. TO RAISE
AWARENESS AND PROVIDE PEER
SUPPORT AND EDUCATION.
REGARDING PATRIARCHY. SEXUAL
VIOLENCE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
DANGERS EMERGE OR WORKERS FACE
WORKING NIGHT SHIFTS AS
JANITORS. HE WAS BELOVED BY HIS
COWORKERS AND THE TENANTS IN
THE RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS HE
WORKED AND- HE WAS IN THE FRONT
LINE OF DEFENDING A TENANT WHEN
HE WAS KILLED. THOSE TENANTS
TOLD STORY AFTER STORY ABOUT
HIS WORTH AT WORK ETHIC AND
WHAT HE DID. TO PROTECT THEM
AND- TO WATCH OUT FOR THE
CLEANLINESS OF THEIR BUILDINGS.
HE WILL BE REMEMBERED AS A
LOVING DEVOTED HUSBAND AND
FATHER WHO HAD JUST REACHED A
MILESTONE OF BUYING HIS
FAMILY'S FIRST HOME. HE WAS A
WARRIOR WHOSE AUTHENTIC VOICE
FOUGHT FOR WHAT HE BELIEVED IN
SHOWING NO FEAR TO MAKE HIS
VOICE HEARD. AND NEVER ON
WILLING TO TAKE ON THE TASK NO
MATTER HOW SMALL OR BIG. THE
MASSES SPEAR THE LEGACY WILL
CARRY ON IN THE LONG STANDING
STRUGGLE. OF THE UNION AND
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. LEAVE OUT THE MASS
MEDIA THIS CONSTANT BUT PUT IT
IN MR MUNNERLYN LUCHA BUT AS
HIS BOTTLE OF GAS THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE US TO. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN A JOURNEY IN MEMORY OF A
CLOSE AT THE MOSQUE MEDIA.
THANK YOU CENTER DRAWS- MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES FORWARD
TO THE DESK SO THAT THEY CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE BY THE
SENATE. THANK YOU. IF THERE IS
NO OTHER BUSINESS CENTERS
CENTERS BERG THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU KIND OF JUST PRESENT
THE NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS
SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY JULY
TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT
TWO PM- WEEKEND THANKS
EVERYBODY THANK YOU SIR HERS
BERG MEMBERS THE SENATE WILL BE
IN RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM
AT WHICH TIME THE GERMAN MOTION
WILL BE PLACED. WE'LL RECONVENE
MONDAY AT TWO PM PLEASE
REMEMBER THERE'S FOUR
COMMITTEES MEETING- KING
FOLLOWING THIS SESSION THANK
YOU HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND.